hi Big Pharma apologist here I'm getting
paid $200,000 to make this video by the
Sackler and Koch brothers are the Koch
brothers in pharma I don't know
no I'm just kidding I want to make this
video on a fake diabetes cure that was
released by Richard girl Houser which is
currently being sued by the FTC for but
before we get into all of that I first
want to talk about big pharma and you
know natural cures because look I'm very
well aware the big pharma has a bunch of
problems obviously they got America
addicted to opiates you know a lot of
these drugs are overpriced etc etc etc
that's it it's a criticism as old as
time and a lot of it there's some
validity to it and I don't think you
should throw out everything but Western
medicine I'm not saying that take your
aspirin and whatever woowoo you want I
think that's fine but what I want to
talk to you guys today about is that the
only thing worse than Big Pharma it's a
lot of these natural health gurus guys
how are we given these guys a pass if
we're gonna criticize the people who
have stuff that works and just say oh
you're over pride that's overpriced what
are we gonna do for the people who have
overpriced stuff that doesn't work when
when are we gonna criticize those guys
okay so look I let me just I'm admitting
big farm apologists right here not
really people are gonna take me serious
I didn't actually get paid for this
video duh
I'm still poor but look yeah Pharma it
sucks but what sucks worse is stuff that
doesn't work that people are trying to
sell you as if it does so who am I
talking about well into Richard gur
Houser Richard gur Houser is a doctor in
Arizona now you might know him from his
stellar reviews on vitals dot-com slash
doctors promoting harmful things fruit
ooh for your health for cash con job
scams $4 dr. gir Howser seems to be
jumping on any wagon hauling cash that
rolls by tinnitus erectile dysfunction
cancer any way to make a buck okay so
there we go
stellar reviews you don't I mean
and what that guy was talking about in
the review is that ger Howser is known
well known for his very aggressive
pitches for all sorts of cures and he's
like you know this will cure cancer like
for example here's a here's when he was
selling magic water here's what it's
called magic water destroys cancer cells
it reminds me of like when the the
right-wing videos were going up like
Jordan Peterson destroys left it's like
magic water destroys cancer cells
doctors really shouldn't be saying magic
water and then destroys cancer cells in
the same breath but okay that's his
choice whatever he's the doctor not me
but then he goes a step too far boys and
actually gets the attention of the FTC
which as we know as we know on this
channel it's very hard to get we have
Dan Locke on this program guys we have I
was about to say it David Wright we have
that guy He Who Shall Not Not Be Named
who quit YouTube because of us we've got
all these guys they're not even enough
to get the attention of the FTC but Gore
Howser did so you know Wow
he must have done a lot so we have the
report we have the lawsuit right here he
was sued by the Federal Trade Commission
for something called a doctor's guide to
reversing 2 diabetes in 28 days now what
did he sell I mean did he show you a
natural cure like diet and exercise new
because that's not really saying
anything new most people know that you
got to give a new pitch so what is this
naturopath you know doctor farmers bad
what does this person do right what does
he say well look at this he goes this
brand new treatment will reverse
diabetes in just four weeks from today
without changing your diet spending a
minute in the gym or taking a single
drug if you know anything about diabetes
type 2 you know
that sounds extremely suspicious because
as we know diabetes can't be cured it's
treated right you get your blood sugar
under control
with diet exercise all these kind of
things this is pretty well-established
knowledge by the Big Pharma that he
criticizes so much and my doctors that
he criticizes so much everyone will tell
you that but he doesn't say that he says
look avoid all that avoid common sense
common knowledge don't do that I'm gonna
tell you a new secret now what does he
sell out for I mean after criticizing
Pharma he gives it away for free right
cuz he's a naturopath doctor he gives
away free no he change are just two
hundred and fifty dollars for a book a
little booklet which he claims is
normally worth a thousand dollars but
he's gonna give it to you because he's
so selfless and he's gonna give it to
you for 250 dollars so what is this
magical thing that we've all been wrong
about all the doctors have been wrong
about well it turns out that the real
cause the root cause of diabetes
according to dr. Richard grosser is NIR
exposure he says the nir exposure alone
could be turning your healthy children
into type 2 diabetics and it could be
doing the same thing to you too he puts
up a little nifty graph about diabetes
rate and electronic devices and just
kind of starts pontificating about how
you know the shocking hidden reasons
that your doctor isn't even testing for
you for that really you need to start
blocking that from your your house and
all that kind of stuff and and and then
you're gonna all of a sudden turn it all
around
right but the big point is that he's
going to cure your diabetes and let you
have your cake and eat it too so to
speak he's gonna make sure you can have
all the foods you know you want which if
you think about it is a pretty dangerous
advice for a diabetic because you're
telling them that at the end of 28 days
they're going to be able to go and just
pig out on these potentially
life-threatening foods or at least very
bad foods for them like look at this
what's the first thing you'll do when
your diabetes is gone will you go out to
your favorite restaurant and enjoy a big
stack of pancakes loaded with syrup
ever having to worry about what it's
gonna do with your blood sugar will you
visit your grandkids
serging with natural all day energy to
chase them around your yard now I know
that sounds like a pipe trade and you're
right to be skeptical but as a medical
doctor with 37 years of experience I can
guarantee if you read this report to the
end and follow these simple instructions
I'm gonna give you just 28 days from now
that dream can be a reality well to that
I say go yourself
oh girl don't say that when you lyin
okay the Federal Trade Commission had to
get involved because of this insane
claim he's saying don't diet and
exercise
apparently the three steps are this the
reverse diabetes defendants say that
Himalayan silk is the first step to the
protocol activating the pancreas
allowing it to pump insulin into the
bloodstream the second step is Epsom
blue and chroma Knight as sugar
companions and then the third steps are
non ionizing radiation blockers in IR
blockers which is what we talked about
earlier the electronic whatever
apparently there are paint paints window
coverings cell phone cases and computer
cases that block NIR that may be you're
supposed to get how insane you're gonna
be one of those guys from like better
call Saul within the house with all the
electronic shields because you think
that's killing you
newsflash it's not there's no evidence
that it is and this guy's profiting off
of your bad situation in order to better
himself so this is why I mean look would
you rather a pill that works or would
you rather this guy selling you a pipe
dream telling you you're gonna eat big
stacks of pancakes it's clear like of
course we all want the pipe dream but
the pipe dream doesn't exist
you know Himalayan silk and ni are
blocking paint isn't gonna save you
sorry to say so that concludes our talk
for now in Richard Kerr Howser we will
be visiting him again because he's done
a lot more than this this is just one of
the many things that he has done and
we're gonna talk about him cuz he's
making he's making up a fortune
of these people man off of his customers
who are hoping to cure all their
diseases just tell me in the comments
below all right tell me in the comments
below
I know farmers not great but would you
rather this guy or would you rather Big
Pharma tell me let me know this is a
Stephen sucking Big Pharma's teat
signing off
[Music]
[Music]
Sakura
[Music]